bien nos habíamos quedado en estas dos
ecuaciones que queremos resolver y en
ellas hay tres incógnitas tenemos a am
como la cantidad de toneladas de acero y
luego tenemos a h como las horas de mano
de obra am y tenemos esta lambda que es
el multiplicador de lagrange que
básicamente es una constante de
proporcionalidad entre estos dos
vectores gradientes entre el vector
gradiente de la función de ingreso y el
vector gradiente de la función
restricción bueno aquí tenemos dos
ecuaciones pero siempre hay una tercera
ecuación con la que estamos trabajando
que es justo está la ecuación de
restricción en sí entonces déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla para que por acá
sigamos trabajando con estas ecuaciones
y para trabajar estas ecuaciones lo que
voy a hacer es simplificar un poco esta
expresión y la forma en la que la voy a
simplificar es introduciendo una nueva
variable a esta nueva variable le voy a
poner el nombre de un
y es que le voy a poner el nombre de um
porque observa lo siguiente aquí tenemos
a / h elevados a la misma potencia
entonces sí digo que un es simplemente
am / h esto se va a simplificar bastante
porque entonces esta primera ecuación me
quedaría de la siguiente manera me va a
quedar como 200 tercios doscientos
tercios que multiplican aa sobre h
elevado a la un tercio aa sobre h
elevado a un tercio es decir un elevado
a la potencia un tercio y bueno esto es
igual a 20 veces lambda
y esta segunda ecuación me va a quedar
de la siguiente manera si hago este
cambio de variable me quedaría 100
tercios 100 tercios que multiplica y
aquí tengo h sobre a entonces aquí va a
ser un elevado a la menos dos tercios y
observa que estoy poniendo a la menos
dos tercios porque aquí tenemos
cambiados h
aquí tenemos sobre h y aquí a h sobre am
por lo tanto me queda con potencia
negativa y bueno claro esto es igual a
2000 lambda
a 2000
ok creo que esto ya se ve mucho más
fácil de resolver
tengo dos ecuaciones y dos incógnitas
ahora lo que se me ocurren es quitar
estas constantes del lado izquierdo y
para eso voy a multiplicar de ambos
lados por su recíproco es decir voy a
multiplicar toda esta ecuación por 3
entre 200 y bueno si hago esto me va a
quedar lo voy a escribir aquí me va a
quedar un elevado al a un tercio esto
igual a 20 lambda por 3 entre 200 bueno
20 entre 200 eso es lo mismo que un 10º
11º por tres son tres decimos tres
décimos de lambda ok esto se ve un poco
más simplificado
y por otra parte tengo esta ecuación de
abajo que voy a multiplicar de ambos
lados por 3 entre 100 para cancelar esta
parte y entonces estos se cancelan y me
queda simplemente un elevado a la menos
dos tercios ok esto igual
y bueno 2000 entre 100 es 20 20 por 360
a 60 a landa ok ahora puedes ver que
estas dos ecuaciones son algo parecidas
entre sí ya que son de la forma o
elevado de alguna potencia igual a algo
por lambda algo tienen de parecido así
que estaría muy bien si dejamos de este
lado solamente
y para hacer esto voy a multiplicar
ambas ecuaciones por un elevado a la dos
tercios sin multiplicó por la primera
observa que de este lado me va a quedar
simplemente 1 y sin multiplicó por la
segunda me va a quedar bueno
aquí me va a quedar 1 y seguramente vas
a decir oye pero
pasa del otro lado pero del otro lado me
va a quedar lambda que multiplica a un
elevado a la dos tercios
así que vamos a hacerlo si multiplicó la
primera por un elevado a las dos tercios
vamos a hacerlo un elevado a la dos
tercios entonces de aquí voy a obtener
lo siguiente voy a obtener bueno igual a
un tercio por igualdad dos tercios es
simplemente uno y esto va a ser igual a
tres
decimos de lambda ok por un ala dos
tercios muy bien y si a esta segunda
ecuación la multiplicó por o elevado a
la dos tercios que voy a obtener bueno
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla porque
esta segunda ecuación me va a quedar de
la siguiente manera me va a quedar como
estos dos se cancelan y me queda
simplemente uno igual a 60 lambda que
multiplica a un elevado a las dos
tercios muy bien ok ahora puedes ver que
el lado derecho es bastante parecido en
ambas ecuaciones y por otra parte el
lado izquierdo es bastante sencillo así
que voy a multiplicar todo lo necesario
para transformar esta primera actuación
en algo que tenga exactamente lo mismo
del lado derecho es decir 60 por lambda
por un elevado a las dos tercios
ahora si observas tenemos aquí lambda
entonces hay que multiplicar por algo
este tres décimos para llegar a 60 y
bueno pueden multiplicar toda esta
ecuación por bueno primero necesito
quitar estos 10 de abajo entonces voy a
multiplicar todo por 10 ok esto se
cancela y después tengo simplemente 33
para 60 habrá que multiplicarlo por 20
entonces se multiplicó toda esta primera
actuación por 10 y por 20 me voy a
obtener bueno en 20 por 10 201 lo voy a
poner aquí 201 igual a 10 por 20 por
tres décimos es lo mismo que 60 lambda
por un lambda por un elevado a la dos
tercios ok
esta es mi primera actuación y mi
segunda ecuación la voy a dejar igual 1
igual a 60 por lambda por un elevado a
la dos tercios muy bien y ahora si estas
dos partes son iguales entonces estos
dos lados izquierdos deben de ser
iguales dicho otra manera
debe de ser igual a 1 ya que estas dos
cosas eran igual a estos lados
complicados y ahora voy a recordar que
uno es igual a entre h entonces esto me
va a quedar como 200 que multiplican a
am / h esto es igual a 1 ok ok de aquí
puedo obtener esto va a ser lo mismo que
200 a 200 y esto es igual a h ok o h es
igual a 200 am así que voy a ocupar esta
ecuación para poder obtener aa
h de que ya tengo una ecuación muy fácil
de trabajar ahora mi segunda ecuación
que también va a ser muy fácil de
trabajar va a ser justo esta otra que
tenemos aquí va a ser la función del
presupuesto
esta que tenemos aquí así que déjame
atraparla me la voy a copiar y la voy a
pegar déjame bajar de nuevo la pantalla
y ahora voy a traer a esa otra ecuación
justo para acá déjame pegarla y bueno
esta va a ser la segunda ecuación con la
que vamos a trabajar de lujo recuerdan
20 pesos que multiplican a cada hora
demanda de obra más 2 mil pesos que
multiplican a cada tonelada de acero
para crear nuestros dispositivos
esto era igual a nuestro presupuesto que
era 20 mil y ahora voy a sustituir en
esta ecuación que tengo aquí esta
información que acabamos de obtener
porque si 200 es igual a h entonces me
quedaría que 20 que multiplica a h
pero h 200 am entonces 20 que multiplica
a 200 a esto que a su vez ésta ha sumado
con 2000
esto tiene que ser igual a 20 mil a 20
mil entonces 20 por 200 es lo mismo que
4 mil 4 mil a más 2000
esto tiene que ser igual a 20.000 ok o
dicho de otra manera seis mil a seis mil
y tiene que ser igual a veinte mil y si
ahora queremos despejar de aquí
entonces voy a obtener que am es igual a
veinte mil entre 6000 cancelamos todos
los ceros y me queda veinte entre seis y
diez tercios diez tercios entonces este
es el valor de amd que nosotros
buscábamos a igual a diez tercios si ya
tenemos esta información déjame ponerlo
a es igual a diez tercios entonces cómo
puedo obtener ahora el valor de h bueno
pues lo tengo aquí h
es igual a 200 pero am vale 10 tercios
entonces h va a ser igual a 200 por 10
tercios y bueno h entonces va a ser
igual a 2000 tercios 2000
tercios que son justos la cantidad de
horas de mano de obra que queremos
mientras que amd es justo la cantidad de
toneladas que necesitábamos entonces si
nosotros regresamos a nuestro ejercicio
original este que teníamos por acá
arriba donde teníamos una función de
ingreso r
que dependía de h idea y era este de
aquí con 20 pesos por hora de mano de
obra y 2 mil pesos por tonelada cero y
un presupuesto de 20 mil pesos entonces
la distribución que deberías hacer en tu
presupuesto sería justo esta que tengo
aquí comprar 10 tercios de toneladas de
acero y gastar en dos mil tercios de
horas de mano de obra y así vas a
obtener el ingreso mayor